Musique intrigante
-L'accès à l'aide active
à mourir
devrait-il être ouvert ?
-A plus de 75 %,
ils ont dit oui à l'ouverture
d'une aide active à mourir.
Applaudissements nourris
La Convention Citoyenne
a rendu ses travaux
et le politique va devoir
en tenir compte.
-C'est génial,
la délibération collective.
-184 citoyens,
9 week-ends, 27 jours
et des débats vifs
sur la façon dont on veut mourir
aujourd'hui en France.
Applaudissements
-Ils ont débattu,
écouté, réfléchi,
changer d'avis parfois aussi.
-On devra parler morale et éthique.
Qu'est-ce que la société veut ?
-C'est les montagnes russes
émotionnelles.
-Moi, ça m'a bouleversé.
-Plongée au coeur des débats
sur une question
à la fois intime et universelle.
...
Musique énigmatique
Durant 4 mois,
le Conseil économique et social
a été le théâtre d'un exercice
démocratique inhabituel.
Le président de la République
a voulu
questionner la société civile
sur la fin de vie.
Une Convention Citoyenne
a été créée.
184 Français et Françaises
rassemblés.
Ils ont
entre 20 et 86 ans.
Ils sont
d'origines géographiques
et sociales très différentes.
Tous ont été
tirés au sort,
et certains
n'en reviennent encore pas.
-On a tous cru
que c'était un gag,
du démarchage téléphonique.
Parce que voilà,
c'est assez incroyable,
finalement.
On est 185, sur la totalité
de la population française.
C'est assez incroyable.
-Leur mission :
dire si la loi actuelle
sur la fin de vie
leur paraît satisfaisante
ou s'il faudrait l'élargir.
-C'est l'aspect
de la démocratie participative,
et même au-delà
de la démocratie,
du fonctionnement
de notre démocratie,
qui m'intéresse beaucoup.
-Je pense qu'on sera
absolument capable
de construire un avis
qui sera solide, qui sera argumenté,
qui se fera
dans des conditions apaisées,
qui sera, à mon avis,
assez proche
de ce qu'est la réalité,
en tout cas
de ce que pense l'opinion.
-Dans tous les esprits,
cette question :
dans quelle mesure
leurs délibérations
vont être entendues
par le politique ?
La Convention sur le climat
a laissé des traces.
Pour les rassurer, la présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale
a voulu clarifier
leur rôle.
...
-Vos délibérations
seront notre boussole,
donc ce sera
pris en compte.
Soyez-en certains.
Je pense qu'il n'y aura pas
un parlementaire
qui n'aura pas lu
chaque page,
chaque ligne, chaque mot
de vos délibérations.
Vous allez être
une pierre
de ce processus délibératif.
Le mur,
nous allons le construire
ensemble.
Vous apporterez
des pierres,
l'Assemblée nationale
en apportera.
Le gouvernement
en apportera,
le Sénat en apportera.
Tous ensemble,
on va construire le mur.
Vous voyez ?
Et moi,
c'est ce en quoi je crois.
Applaudissements
Musique dynamique
-Mais avant tout, rappel
de ce que dit la loi actuelle
sur la fin de vie.
-On commence cette audition
par un échange
avec Alain Claeys.
Alain Claeys,
il a été député
entre 1997 et 2017,
coauteur de la loi dite
Claeys-Leonetti.
-Bonjour à toutes
et à tous.
-Les citoyens vont apprendre
que cette loi autorise
dans certains cas le recours
à la sédation profonde et continue.
-Cette sédation n'est possible
qu'en phase terminale,
quand le patient
est certain
de décéder à court terme.
Les citoyens réalisent
qu'elle est
très restrictive.
-Pourquoi certains patients
atteints de maladies
neurodégénératives,
telles que la maladie de Charcot
ou de Parkinson,
étaient exclus
du cadre de cette loi ?
-Chacun arrive
avec ses références,
sa culture,
ses croyances.
-Il me semble
complètement anormal
que des citoyens français aisés
puissent aller en Suisse,
en Belgique, en Espagne,
au Portugal,
comme le faisaient
les femmes
il y a 50 ou 60 ans
pour interrompre
une grossesse,
en mettant leur vie
en danger...
Il me semble anormal
que nous soyons
dans cette situation.
-D'autres ont
un vécu particulier
et des opinions
bien tranchées.
-J'aimerais
que la loi existe.
J'ai la sclérose en plaques.
Je me suis toujours dit
que je n'aimerais pas
terminer dans un lit,
sans savoir trop bouger.
-Au départ,
je suis plutôt contre.
Avec des soins palliatifs
plus performants,
il y aurait quand même
beaucoup de situations
où les gens pourraient
vivre encore quelques jours.
Parfois, ces jours-là,
ils sont fondamentaux.
Musique de tension
...
-Justement,
le week-end suivant,
ils vont pouvoir appréhender
les modèles choisis
par la Belgique et la Suisse
quand elles ont légalisé
l'aide active à mourir.
-J'appelle tout de suite
Corinne Vaysse-van Oost,
Claudia Magri et Irène Ta.
Applaudissements
...
-Je travaille en Belgique
depuis plus de 30 ans,
dans le cadre
des soins palliatifs.
Qui peut demander
l'euthanasie ?
Un patient majeur,
capable et conscient,
et un patient mineur,
ce qui a été une évolution en 2014,
à condition qu'il ait
une capacité de discernement.
La demande est formulée
de manière volontaire,
réfléchie et répétée.
Le patient doit se trouver
dans une situation médicale
sans issue,
faire état
d'une souffrance physique
ou psychique constante,
insupportable,
qui ne peut être apaisée.
Nous avons beaucoup
de demandes d'euthanasie,
mais peu d'actes.
-Beaucoup ont entendu parler
de la mort
de Jean-Luc Godard.
Ce jour-là,
ils découvrent le modèle suisse,
le suicide assisté,
où le patient
se donne lui-même la mort,
et où les associations
comme Dignitas
jouent un rôle majeur.
Musique tonique
-Je vois déjà que d'un côté,
en Suisse,
on a une association,
alors que de l'autre côté,
en Belgique,
c'est vraiment le système
et l'organisation sanitaire,
qui se préoccupe de ça.
-J'ai trouvé que le schéma belge
était intéressant,
car il mettait le médecin traitant
au coeur du système.
-Le sujet interroge.
Même après
deux heures de conférence,
les citoyens veulent
prolonger le moment.
Même en Belgique,
on n'euthanasie que des gens
qui ont encore tout leur esprit.
-J'euthanasie des gens qui,
jusqu'au bout, me disent :
"C'est ce que je veux."
Il y a la question
de la démence.
Des familles me disent :
"Ma mère, en ayant
son diagnostic, elle a dit :
"'Si j'ai une démence,
je mourrai par euthanasie.'
"Et maintenant,
elle n'a plus sa tête.
"Elle pense qu'elle a 50 ans,
30 ou 20,
"et elle ne le demande plus.
"Nous, on la voit
se dégrader
"et c'est pas digne,
alors qu'elle en avait parlé."
-Le débat
sur la fin de vie
convoque aussi
notre conception morale,
éthique et religieuse
de l'existence.
Quel regard
portent les représentants
des catholiques, des protestants,
des musulmans ou des juifs
sur la question
de l'aide active à mourir ?
Partagent-ils
la même opinion ?
-Pouvez-vous nous rappeler
ce que dit votre religion
de la fin de vie ?
-Nous ne disons pas
que Dieu nous retire la vie,
à la fin
de la vie terrestre,
mais nous disons
qu'il nous accueille avec lui
et que la vie
que nous recevons
est une vie transformée
à la fin de notre vie terrestre.
-Comme les catholiques,
les autres cultes estiment
que seul Dieu, créateur de la vie,
est le maître des horloges.
-On ne peut pas décider
de se laisser mourir.
Là également,
nous nous accrochons désespérément
à la volonté de Dieu.
-Pour tous,
si on légalisait
l'aide active à mourir,
ceci équivaudrait à un changement
de civilisation,
quitte à grossir le trait.
-Un jour, on vous dira :
"Dès que vous ne courez plus
le 100 mètres
"en 12 ou 13 secondes,
"dès que vous n'arrivez plus
à jouer un match de football
"de deux fois 45 minutes,
"vous n'êtes plus apte
à exister dans la société."
-La question
qui se pose à vous aujourd'hui,
et je cite le grand rabbin,
est "une rupture".
Vous parliez
d'une "rupture anthropologique".
Jusqu'à présent, notre loi
accompagne la mort.
La question qui se pose,
si on fait évoluer, c'est :
est-ce qu'on bouge, finalement,
vers le don de la mort ?
-Un point de vue
pas forcément partagé
par les croyants.
Les pratiquants,
quelle que soit leur religion,
se déclarent dans les sondages
grandement favorables
à l'aide active à mourir.
D'ailleurs, ce jour-là,
les conventionnels
sont peu sensibles
aux discours des religieux.
-A titre laïc,
ça ne me touche pas,
et je considère
que les arguments dogmatiques,
ce qu'on peut nommer ainsi,
car ça appartient
à un ensemble de croyances,
n'ont pas à avoir
droit de cité dans le débat.
-Je suis issu
de la religion catholique,
mais ça n'empêche pas que...
La loi est ce qu'elle est,
mais nous sommes des citoyens,
et la vie, elle évolue.
Les temps changent,
alors il faudrait, je pense,
quand même se mettre
à la page.
Musique douce
...
-Mais bientôt, les citoyens
font face à des mots qui vont
les faire vaciller.
Cet après-midi,
médecins et infirmières
en soins palliatifs
témoignent.
Le message est simple :
avant de changer la loi,
encore faudrait-il l'appliquer.
Faute de lits,
deux tiers des personnes
gravement malades
meurent sans avoir accès
aux soins palliatifs.
-Je viens de la ruralité.
On n'a pas de soins palliatifs.
Il y a pas de place
en soins de suite, en EHPAD.
Les familles sont déroutées.
Les familles,
elles m'ont dit aussi :
"Pourquoi la loi,
elle n'est pas appliquée ?
"Pourquoi les gens n'ont pas accès
aux soins palliatifs ?"
-Ce qui manque aux soignants
que nous sommes,
c'est le temps
à accompagner,
justement,
à être présents.
-Quant au fait de permettre
l'aide active à mourir,
elle leur paraît
contre-nature.
-On n'a pas fait ce métier
pour aider
un patient à mourir.
C'est pas possible,
pour moi.
C'est pas possible du tout,
du tout, du tout, du tout,
du tout, du tout, du tout.
-Selon eux,
les demandes d'euthanasie
baisseraient
quand la prise en charge
en soins palliatifs
est efficiente.
-Ca m'interpelle sur des choses
que j'avais pas imaginées.
-Si les problématiques
ne sont pas déjà réglées à la base,
c'est-à-dire
le manque de personnel,
le manque de moyens,
le manque de formations,
comment on peut évoluer
dans la décision,
dans la question
qui nous est posée ?
-On a eu une quasi unanimité
des soignants,
médecins, infirmières,
accompagnants,
contre l'euthanasie.
Ouais, ça, je peux le dire.
Moi, ça m'a bouleversé.
Musique de tension
-Après ce week-end,
les conventionnels réalisent
plus que jamais à quel point
la question
qu'on leur a posée
est complexe et multiforme.
...
Retour au débat.
Nous sommes en janvier
et les citoyens vont être plongés
dans le grand bain des arguments
pour ou contre
l'aide active à mourir,
avec un face-à-face détonnant.
-Je préside l'Association pour
le Droit à Mourir dans la Dignité.
-Je suis médecin à Narbonne
et je préside
la Société Française
d'Accompagnement
et de Soins Palliatifs,
qui est la maison commune
des soins palliatifs.
-Nous partons du principe
que les soins palliatifs
ne peuvent pas tout.
-L'hôpital est dans un état
très difficile,
et si les soignants partent
en rangs aussi serrés actuellement,
c'est parce que
ce qu'on leur demande
n'a pas de sens pour eux.
-Si les soins palliatifs
ne peuvent pas tout
et si la loi aujourd'hui
ne permet pas
pour l'ADMD
et pour beaucoup de Français,
d'accompagner tous les parcours
en fin de vie,
nous souhaitons aussi
la légalisation
de l'aide active à mourir,
de l'euthanasie
et du suicide assisté.
-C'est 2 % de l'ensemble
des acteurs de soins palliatifs
qui nous disent
pouvoir envisager l'euthanasie.
-Ce n'est pas, demain,
l'aide active à mourir pour tous.
Mais ce qu'on souhaite,
c'est que chacun
puisse avoir ce choix.
-A partir du moment
où il y a une loi,
toutes les personnes
sont obligées de l'envisager,
c'est-à-dire
que la présence de la loi
fait que chacun
va être amené à se demander
si ce serait mieux pour lui,
pour ses proches,
pour la société,
qu'il fasse ce choix.
-Je ne suis pas le méchant qui dit :
"Ta vie ne compte pas."
"On va te donner l'aide active
à mourir, car tu l'as demandée."
On peut partir
dans toutes ces théories,
sauf qu'on va dans un débat inverse.
Je propose un débat qui cadre.
-Dans deux semaines
vont commencer les phases
de délibération.
Chaque citoyen
doit se forger un avis.
Musique intrigante
-Je me nourris
de tous ces échanges.
Je pense que c'est important,
d'avoir ces deux positions.
Ca nous avait manqué,
pendant les deux premières sessions
et c'était nécessaire
que ça arrive maintenant,
qu'on ait justement
ce début de débat contradictoire
avec des positions
qui commencent à s'affronter.
-Il y a des oscillations.
"Ce n'est pas faux, ce qu'il a dit."
Et puis après, quelqu'un va venir
donner un contre-exemple :
"Ah oui, c'est vrai."
C'est les montagnes russes
émotionnelles.
-Les arguments théoriques
deviennent soudain
tout à fait concrets.
La prochaine audition
va replacer le malade
au centre du débat.
Nathalie Maka appartient
à une famille
qui porte un gène responsable
de la maladie de Charcot.
Une maladie qui ronge
les fonctions motrices
jusqu'à ce que
le patient meure étouffé.
*-J'étais, à 14 ans,
une jeune aidante.
Mon papa est décédé
il y a plus de 25 ans.
Ma grand-mère,
qui a eu 11 enfants,
en a perdu 6
dans la fratrie de mon papa.
Aujourd'hui, mes cousins
et cousines en meurent.
Et je vois partir
un membre de ma famille
tous les deux ans.
-Nathalie Maka
a vu mourir sa cousine
dans des conditions atroces,
avec une sédation
qui s'est éternisée.
Elle a vu son frère se suicider.
Autant dire que la loi actuelle est,
selon elle, inadaptée.
-La loi Claeys-Leonetti,
elle est imparfaite.
On va préférer parfois
- je m'excuse, déjà,
pour le corps médical
qui ne va pas
être d'accord -
laisser mourir de faim
et de soif,
pour ne pas prendre
la responsabilité
d'aller au bout de cet acte.
Et l'éthique, à un moment,
je pense
qu'il faut prendre le temps
de se dire
qu'on doit être raisonnable
et qu'on doit donner
à des personnes
l'occasion,
si elles souhaitent,
de s'en aller dignement.
Et oui, on a
des demandes d'euthanasie.
C'est une maladie létale,
la maladie de Charcot.
La question ne se pose pas.
On devrait avoir le droit de dire :
"Je veux m'en aller."
-Clairement, là,
c'est du concret.
Elle dit bien que oui,
c'est un besoin pour tous,
de pouvoir mourir dignement
et de choisir sa mort, oui.
-Là, on arrive vraiment
dans des personnes
qui ont un diagnostic vital
qui est engagé
sur le court, moyen,
voire long terme,
si on sait qu'on a le gène,
mais qu'on n'est pas encore
en capacité
de déclencher la maladie.
Ca, c'est des situations
qui peuvent poser débat,
pour alimenter la décision
qui découlera de nos travaux.
-Mais avant de trancher
la délicate question
de l'aide active à mourir,
les citoyens veulent
interpeller le politique
sur un impératif absolu.
Depuis des semaines,
toutes opinions confondues,
les participants sont frappés
par un constat :
le traitement de la douleur,
l'accompagnement vers la mort
ne sont pas à la hauteur
des besoins,
faute de moyens.
*-Quand la fin de la vie
se rapproche,
il faut que l'on ait besoin
d'anticiper cette fin de vie.
-D'ateliers en ateliers,
l'état des lieux est alarmant.
-Quels sont les chiffres ?
C'est qu'il manque 50 médecins
ou il en manque 5000 ?
Il manque une unité
de soins palliatifs
ou il en manque
10, 20, 30 ?
-Les médecins sont un peu
aussi forcés
par le système de l'hôpital
à ne pas passer beaucoup de temps
avec les patients
et plutôt à faire des actes
et tout ça.
-D'autant que
dans les années à venir,
les besoins de soins palliatifs
vont être exponentiels.
*-Il y a 10 %
de gens qui ont plus de 75 ans,
actuellement,
mais il y en aura 20 %
dans quelques années.
Parce que c'est les progrès
de la médecine.
-Alors, ils vont s'entendre
sur près de 65 mesures concrètes
à remettre à la Première ministre
pour que les soins palliatifs
ne soient plus le parent pauvre
de l'hôpital.
Musique haletante
...
*-Proposition 26 :
fixer pour chaque région
des objectifs
de couverture exhaustive
en soins palliatifs
pour 100 % de la population
de la région.
Le vote est ouvert.
-Aujourd'hui, plus d'une vingtaine
de départements sont dépourvus
d'unités de soins palliatifs.
...
*-La proposition est acceptée
avec 69 %.
*-Obliger les EHPAD
à avoir du personnel
formé en soins palliatifs.
-Les EHPAD sont démunis
de soins palliatifs,
alors que c'est l'endroit
où meurent 20 % des Français.
*-La proposition est acceptée
à 91 %.
*-Dans le cadre d'une sédation
profonde et continue
à domicile,
renforcer l'accompagnement
des proches.
Le vote est ouvert.
-Car aujourd'hui,
les proches aidants sont
les grands oubliés de la loi.
*-La proposition est acceptée
à 83 %.
-Désormais,
reste le sujet qui fâche,
le plus clivant :
celui de l'aide active à mourir.
Les citoyens ont planché
par groupes
pour lister les conditions
qui seraient indispensables,
selon eux,
pour pouvoir prétendre
à l'aide active à mourir.
*-Le temps qui arrive,
il a pour objectif
de partager vos arguments
sur l'accès
à l'aide active à mourir.
-Tous s'entendent pour dire
que le patient doit avoir
son libre arbitre.
Mais faut-il qu'il soit condamné ?
-Autre question
très clivante :
cet acte peut-il
être possible
pour des mineurs ?
*-Un cancer pédiatrique,
c'est un cancer.
Pourquoi on pourrait satisfaire
la demande d'un adulte
et pas celle d'un enfant ?
-La question des mineurs,
c'est :
s'il y a désaccord avec les parents,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
J'aimerais bien qu'on en discute.
-Et que dire
des dépressifs chroniques
qui demanderaient
une euthanasie ?
-Ca m'interroge
sur des maladies
où l'envie de mourir
et la pensée suicidaire sont
un symptôme à part entière
de la maladie.
Ca peut être le cas
d'un syndrome dépressif sévère.
Est-ce que, finalement,
l'aide active à mourir n'est pas
une façon un peu radicale
de soigner ce symptôme ?
Je pose la question.
*-Lorsqu'il a été question
d'avancer, de légiférer
sur une question sociétale,
il y a toujours cette crainte
de la dérive possible,
de la ligne rouge.
80 : abolition
de la peine de mort.
Il y aura beaucoup plus
de criminalité dans notre pays.
Est-ce qu'on rencontre
cette situation dans notre pays ?
Faisons confiance aussi
à notre société pour s'autoréguler.
Je comprends que,
quand on doit légiférer
sur une question de société,
ça bouscule,
mais il faut aussi
ne pas faire en sorte
que ça soit un frein
pour évoluer.
Applaudissements nourris
-Bravo !
-Les débats sont vifs,
débordant même
le cadre de l'hémicycle.
-Au vu des moyens,
au vu de la société,
au vu des choses
qui vont se passer
par rapport
à ce qu'on va faire,
il y aura forcément
des évolutions à amener.
-Il y a une position hypocrite
qui serait d'entrouvrir la porte,
en disant : "Oui, mais on va
la barricader à quelques cas."
Tout en sachant que ces cas vont
inéluctablement sauter
par l'évolution de la loi
et de la société.
-Plus qu'un week-end
pour finaliser
leurs recommandations.
Dernier jour de l'ultime session
et le vote d'un texte
de 150 pages argumentées
pour créer un modèle français
de l'aide active à mourir.
*-Notre Convention a répondu
à 97 %
que le cadre d'accompagnement
de la fin de vie
doit être amélioré.
*-Pour 76 % d'entre nous,
l'accès à l'aide active à mourir
doit être ouvert.
Concernant les formes d'accès
à l'aide active à mourir,
la Convention Citoyenne a fait
émerger une position majoritaire,
celle de la nécessité
de mettre en place
suicide assisté
et euthanasie
avec de nombreuses nuances,
reflet de la complexité du sujet.
-Pour y avoir accès,
le patient devrait avoir
une maladie incurable
et faire preuve
de discernement.
Mais pour les mineurs,
c'est non.
Pour ne pas heurter les soignants,
les citoyens leur ont donné
une échappatoire.
*-Concernant l'implication
des personnels soignants,
la Convention a adopté le principe
d'une clause de conscience.
-Après quatre mois de travail,
ces 184-là ont l'impression
d'avoir vécu un moment privilégié
grâce à la Convention.
-C'était génial
parce que c'est quelque chose
d'unique dans une vie,
de pouvoir réfléchir
avec autant de monde,
d'arriver à le faire,
et de voir qu'à la fin,
on a réussi à construire
quelque chose de cohérent.
-C'est une aventure extraordinaire.
On se retrouve avec des gens
qu'on n'aurait jamais rencontrés
autrement.
-Je ne saisis toujours pas,
je ne réalise toujours pas
d'avoir participé à ça.
Mais ça fait quelque chose, quoi.
-Un processus plein d'enseignements
au-delà du thème de la fin de vie.
-Sur la démocratie,
ça nous dit des choses.
Quand on nous en donne
l'opportunité,
quand on nous fait confiance,
on est capables et on a envie
de produire quelque chose.
Et c'est ça qui est très beau.
-J'espère que ça continuera
et qu'il y aura
d'autres Conventions Citoyennes
pour traiter des sujets
aussi importants
et peut-être difficiles,
avec le même respect.
-Je me dis, comme mes collègues :
la Convention se termine,
mais le débat s'ouvre.
On continue et on espère
que le débat s'ouvrira au parlement.
-Les cartes sont désormais
entre les mains
du président de la République
qui a demandé qu'un texte
soit présenté
en Conseil des ministres
avant la fin de l'été.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA